we all remember the case of then high
school student nicholas sandman he was
smeared slandered besmirched by the
media mob as a hateful racist because he
was wearing a maga hat and now sandman
has published an op-ed on
dailymail.com offering his support to
written house slamming the media for
spewing their endless lies about kyle at
the end of the piece sandman addresses
rittenhouse directly writing quote at
this time i would like to use my
platform to let kyle know that i'm here
for you and if you would ever like to
reach out to me
about the only person our age to have an
idea of how the media is treating you
and you don't have to face this alone
joining us now for an exclusive
interview is nicholas sandman
nicholas thank you for joining us
i remember at the time
what you were going through and i
remember that moment
and then the facts started coming out
that everything that was said about you
that you had walked over to this native
american activist for example uh that
you had uh in fact that you were a
racist you you had the same false
accusations leveled against you
and i remember thinking
you had when we when the facts came out
you you handled this as perfectly i felt
as any kid could
my question to you is
what is the impact on on the psychic on
the mind
being thrust into the public eye like
that um being called things that you are
not things that are not true and then i
want to ask you what you think kyle
should do
well it's terrible sean and i'll tell
you why
as in
17 year old in kyle's case in mind 16
your mind is still developing and so to
deal
with an overload of stress where you
have this feeling that
um half of the country
hundreds of millions of people hate you
for
something that you're innocent of
but how you were painted
it can do a lot to you mentally
it takes a very strong will
to be able to resist that and keep a
level head and i know that kyle is
probably dealing with that right now
you said in this article the parallels
between me and kyle rittenhouse are
impossible not to draw
and that you think that kyle rittenhouse
should sue outlets to quote hold the
media accountable
i know that you have entered into
settlements that i'm sure there are
non-disclosure agreements you can't talk
about
i know cnn is one and there are ongoing
cases if i'm not mistaken is that
correct
that's correct i'm currently still suing
six media outlets
and well and tell us what you think and
why you think kyle should hold the media
accountable and let me ask you this i
would like your opinion based on joe
biden's tweet do you think he should
also look at the idea of suing joe biden
well i think he should sue the media but
it's really a personal call that's up to
him
in january it'll be three years since
everything happened
at the march for life and i'm still
looking at another two years
until the cases that go to trial are
resolved so it's really a personal call
for him i know he has a lot on his plate
on whether he wants to entrench himself
in this but
on the topic of joe biden i've heard a
lot of debate about it but i think plain
and simple that
unfortunately calling someone a racist
or a white supremacist
uh is an opinion protected by the first
amendment
uh personally i know it because many of
the claims that
we
labeled as defamatory were not let in by
the judge
in federal court and so
i i would like to see him go after joe
biden i'd like to to see where that goes
but i don't think kyle's in the case
where he can be
making lawsuits just to
see what happens he doesn't have the
luxury of suing everyone just to see if
any of them land you know it's
interesting i i learned a lot and your
first attorney was lynn wood who i've
known for years and he was richard
jewell's attorney and i was a local
radio host in atlanta at the time and a
big article came out in the atlanta
journal constitution and it said uh that
the that in that case richard jewell fit
the profile of the lone bomber
because he lives with his mother i
didn't know at the time that richard
jewell was listening to my radio program
and i said
excuse me just because he lives with his
mom does not make him a domestic
terrorist it turns out he was not
responsible in the end he was a hero
it has served me well
because i don't rush to judgment this
show doesn't do that we allow for the
presumption of innocence and due process
as we did but frankly in your case i
don't know if you watched any of the
coverage
and we were right on ferguson missouri
cambridge police we're right on duke
lacrosse we're right on uva we're right
on freddie gray in baltimore we're right
on the russia hoax for for three to four
years of never-ending conspiracy
theories and lies you have the same
group of people nicholas that always
rush to judgment never afford due
process or the presumption of innocence
that's why i believe you are right in
doing what you're doing because this has
to end
because they're destroying people's
lives you're a young man and i can tell
just from this interview this has not
destroyed your life but it could have
i'm sure you had many
difficult days in the in the process of
being labeled the world's biggest racist
yes it was terrible for multiple months
and
while i i don't speak about it often it
has been hard to
kind of come back from
the state i was in i did watch a lot of
fox and
cnn msnbc i watched everything after
the confrontation happened and it was
like
a car crash you aren't able to look away
from i my eyes were glued to the tv
watching my character get torn apart
and i know kyle will
face that journey of kind of getting
back to the person that he was before of
course he won't ever be the same person
again but it definitely is a struggle
you pointed out this is a big problem
with the news media in this country and
you took them on
and it looks like although you can't
talk about it that you're winning and i
would imagine you have a very strong
case in each instance
um and i would predict probably a very
positive outcome for you and you urge
kyle to to consider this this process as
well
um how has it changed you
because it certainly
you seem
you seem stronger as a result of it
uh a lot of people probably would have
crumbled and and never recovered you
seem to have recovered
yeah well
the biggest thing that happened to me
and what i've always said is i became an
adult at 16
and um i had to learn very quickly
that you know the moment i left my house
there could be a camera on me and i i've
learned to
look around and look over my shoulder in
public not everyone likes me
and it doesn't matter where i am i still
get recognized
by people all over even today so
it makes you unfortunately grow up in a
lot of ways that
most 18 year olds don't want to do and
that's just the unfortunate reality of
what happens when the mainstream media
attacks you in the way that
they did to me and to kyle i don't think
you could have handled it more perfectly
and um
i i applaud the fact that you were able
to withstand that grow and and obviously
you're moving on with your life i do
hope that kyle rittenhouse you offered
him an opportunity to reach out to you
and i think you're right you're probably
the only person uh in that age group
that would really understand what he's
been through uh nicholas salman we wish
you all the best in your future and
thank you for being with us